الاعتقاد هو أنها لعبة رسوم متحركة
ربما تبلغ 120
أمتار وهي لعبة خروج المغلوب
كما قلت كما قلت لأنه لم يتوقع أحد
منا أن نكون هنا كما تعلمون أننا نلقي
بكل شيء عليهم وليس هناك
ضغط حقيقي علينا وكما قلت
أم  إلى جميع الأولاد الذين شاركوا في هذه
البطولة وأيضًا
ما أعتقد
أنك ستحصل على أفضل
ما لديك هو فقط القيام بما قمت به
طوال حياتك المهنية للوصول إلى هنا
والتعبير عن نفسك ،
أنت تعلم أنني اخترت فقط كل واحد منا
لأنه هو
يختار هؤلاء اللاعبين الذين سيقومون
بعمل ما وأنت تعلم أن
ما كانوا يفعلونه في أنديتهم لذلك
ليس لدينا أي ضغط حقيقي نحتاج فقط
لأن تعلموا الاستمتاع باللحظة واستمتعوا بهذه
المناسبة واه كما أنا  قلت أنك تعلم أن لا
أحد يتوقع منا الفوز ، لذلك دعونا نصدم
العالم